some care homes were struggling
financially even before the outbreak of
coronavirus but Sky News can reveal a
group of care homes in the northeast of
England have taken the unprecedented
step of legally warning the council if
they don't take action to help them
financially within five days the market
will start to collapse we've obtained a
leaked copy of a letter from 21 care
homes to North Tyneside Council
declaring force majeure or a major
incident the letter says the care home
market within North Tyneside is facing
imminent collapse due to the council's
conduct in the lead-up to and during the
current kovat 19 pandemic it goes on the
council has failed to provide sufficient
and timely financial support to care
home providers to meet the additional
costs they're incurring due to covert 19
as vacancies increased due to deaths
with fewer and fewer if any new
admissions the running of homes within
North Tyneside is becoming increasingly
unsustainable the largest representative
body for social care in the UK is Care
England I asked them to comment on the
letter we already knew that the care
sector was really struggling financially
to deal with this pandemic but how much
more serious is it to declare a force
majeure or major incident declaring this
force majeure is something that has
never really happened before so this
tells us that we are in the midst of
that's the worst situation we have seen
in modern times what would you say to
people who have relatives in care homes
and nursing homes in this country care
providers will be doing everything to
make sure that the care is as good as it
possibly can be and that people have
good lives though where they should
worry is whether or not these services
are sustainable for the long term
declaring force majeure essentially
frees both parties from their
obligations under the contract due to
extraordinary events in certain
specified circumstances those
circumstances would normally include
such things as war riots acts of
terrorism earthquake or flood or
whatever
in a statement North Tyneside Council
said we're working hard together to keep
staff and residents safe occupancy
levels have been affected by the
pandemic and we're aware levels have
fallen below where they were ordinarily
expected to be where this has happened
we're working with those providers
directly in line with our statutory duty
it's not just the northeast of England
where anger is growing about the costs
of combating coronavirus in care homes
scams
large groups of we were thankfully ahead
of the curve so we had the sufficient to
keep us rolling but then we were paying
exorbitant prices for maths in clubs
some care homes say they feel they've
been pushed to take drastic action and
they're still fighting the devastating
impact of coronavirus Lisa Holland Sky
News